let's reset what's going on with krump
attorney Michael Cohen we learned last
week because of initially tweets from
stormy Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
we learned that Michael Cohen through a
shell company called essential
consultants was the recipient of more
than a million dollars that we know of
specifically and allegedly of more than
four million dollars of basically
influence money six hundred thousand
dollars from AT&T 1.2 million dollars
from big from Switzer a pharmaceutical
company Novartis
reportedly five hundred thousand dollars
from a Putin connected Russian business
owner billionaire and allegedly many
many other transfers of money and
supposedly the reason that these
companies were paying Michael Cohen's a
consulting firm was for insights into
the Trump administration and of course
the timing was very suspect the timing
of the AT&T money 600,000 not 200,000 as
originally reported coincided with not
only the repeal of net neutrality by the
Trump FCC but also with the fact that
AT&T was trying to merge with Time
Warner The Washington Post has now
obtained internal AT&T documents meaning
this is what AT&T wrote internally about
the real reasons why they were paying
money to Michael Cohen and the internal
documents from AT&T indicate that hiring
Michael Cohen was done to help with the
Time Warner merger AT&T hired the
personal attorney of the President of
the United States to provide advice
about a merger which Trump's own
Department of Justice would be
adjudicating so this is a story about
corruption fundamentally it should not
be a partisan story because corruption
cuts both ways much like freedom of the
press and it can be very tempting to
look the other way when the lack of
press freedom or of corrosive corruption
is helping your side but that's how we
end up screwing ourselves in the long
run and this is quickly growing to the
level of I mean I don't know to pick an
example the corruption during the
presidency of ulysses s grant which was
considered huge right it included Black
Friday in
at a major railroad scam it included the
whiskey ring pond-scum corruption and
cronyism what we are seeing now under
the Trump administration in terms of
corruption and cronyism is rising above
and beyond even what we saw under
president ulysses s grant and this is
circumstantial evidence of bribery right
the AT&T hiring of Michael Cohen
Novartis the other companies were
learning about and it's not about
bribery the crime yet but it is deduced
evidence of intent to bribe and receive
bribes and it has to be looked into and
Americans should be united on this
they're not and that is really one of
the scariest things that we're seeing
about the looking the other way on Trump
Russia looking the other way on the
cronyism looking the other way on the
broader bamboozling that has taken place
because this has every indication of
being pay to play which by the way Trump
said was a reason not to vote for
Hillary selling access directly or
indirectly explicitly or implicitly to
the President of the United States and
we only have the information so far
about some of the more than four million
dollars that supposedly ran through this
one company of Cohen's essential
consultants I would be willing to bet
that there is much more and I hope that
we learn about it soon and and it's
important I mentioned legally right some
will say okay
AT&T paid Cohen to help get the merger
approved Trump hates CNN owned by Time
Warner Trump opposed the deal anyway
is it still illegal is it still bribery
even if it wasn't successful bribery and
the answer from legal experts is yes the
offer of a quid pro quo is what makes it
bribery taking money to help get a
merger through getting screwed because
Trump's Justice Department ended up
opposing it doesn't excuse the bribery
we could call it stupid bribery we could
call it failed bribery but it is still
bribery and of course whether there's
going to be any legal repercussions
remains to be seen I am really
disappointed that we're not seeing both
sides put their foot down and say that
this is not democracy
and because corruption is everywhere in
our politics it's unclear as to whether
or not Michael Cohen even committed a
crime here but if he did commit a crime
you have to imagine that Robert Miller
would use that to his advantage because
he already has Michael Cohen at the palm
of his hand right if you would think
what the Russia stuff and the stormy
Danielle stuff he could use this as
leverage to maybe that would cause
Michael Cohen to flip on Trump that's
increasingly the discussion I mean we've
known that Cohen has been a likely
indite e of robert muller for a while
and at this point the questions are
number one is this something Moeller is
concerned with we believe the answer is
yes because we know Cohen spoke to both
AT&T and Novartis months ago so clearly
Cohen knows about this question too is
there a point at which Michael Cohen's
supposed the love of Donald Trump just
thinking he's just the best guy out
there is there a point at which it was
even going it would become too much
pressure even on Cohen and Cohen does
flip I don't know the answer to that but
it is something that we may soon learn
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and boy do we have a good
program for you today today's episode of
the program is made possible in part by
Coins schedule a listing site for
initial coin offerings that's been
around since 2016 was actually one of
the first websites to show listing
information about icos
you can look them up by name type of
Industry the icos end date the start
date and it also gives each IC o---- a
score using an algorithm based on dozens
of parameters to help you determine how
trustworthy an IC o---- is very
important to be able to filter out scams
so for example whether or not the
identities of the IC o---- team are
verified is listed by coin schedule
whether the IC o---- has a white paper
these types of parameters and coin
schedule also doesn't try to make
predictions about the long-term success
or failure of any IC o---- project since
this is often impossible what they do
instead is provide users with a combined
score of how much operational risk coin
schedule sees for each different IC
o---- so that you can know when you've
got to be careful with icos that have a
low rating if you're watching this on
youtube I've put a link to the coin
schedule website at
top of the video description and of
course nothing in coin schedule should
be considered personalized investment
advice I cos are risky people should do
their own research and make their own
decisions